[Música]
Twitter estrena directora ejecutiva la
neoyorquina linda yacarino asumió como
ceo de la red social Todo comenzó en
diciembre cuando elon musk hizo una
encuesta a través de Twitter en la que
preguntaba si debía retirarse o no de la
dirección de la compañía lo que no
implicaba dejar de ser su dueño fue
tendencia con 17 millones y medio de
votos de los cuales el 57% le pidió que
se hiciera a un lado
mosc afirmó que renunciaría y cinco
meses después también a través de una
publicación dio la noticia de quién iba
a ser su reemplazo
estoy emocionado de darle la bienvenida
a Linda yacarino como la nueva de
Twitter linda jaccarino se centrará
principalmente en las operaciones
comerciales mientras que yo me centraré
en el diseño de productos y nuevas
tecnologías espero trabajar con Linda
para transformar esta plataforma en x la
aplicación para todo
se esperaba que ya Karina comenzara su
nuevo rol alrededor del 22 de junio pero
se adelantó y asumió como la nueva
directora de Twitter esta semana y al
igual que Mask lo anunció a través de la
red social
sucedió primer día en los libros
manténganse conectados
la gran pregunta ahora es si Twitter
seguirá abriendo espacios para los
discursos de odio lo que ha sido una
tendencia desde que elon musk compró la
red social en octubre del año pasado
osilinda yacarino podrá cambiar de rumbo
y volver a Twitter un espacio en el que
no haya ataques de raza género sexo ni
por las tendencias políticas podrá
cambiar la imagen pública que ha tomado
esta red social Esto es lo que
discutiremos en el debate Hoy estamos en
nuestro estudio con Andrea Cardona
periodista de tecnología podcaster y
directora del programa RCN digital en el
medio colombiano RCN radio desde Buenos
Aires se conecta Joan suayc autorio
divulgador especialista en tecnología y
sociedad y en Estambul está Simón
Hernández periodista y analista de
tecnología a todos ellos Bienvenidos a
nuestro programa y a ustedes nuestros
televidentes les recordamos que también
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
todos sus comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales Twitter
Facebook e Instagram estamos como arroba
France 24 raya al piso es los leemos con
el numeral el debate f24 y a mí me
encuentran como arroba María claguirre
pero no solo estamos en las pantallas
también encuentran nuestros podcast en
Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
Comencemos Entonces le quiero dar la
bienvenida a Andrea Cardona Andrea
Gracias por estar aquí con nosotros la
primera pregunta de todos es linda
jacarino podrá cambiar el rumbo Bueno
gracias por la invitación y yo creo que
está muy difícil el rumbo que tiene que
asumir ella también para poder sacar de
las cenizas lo que queda de Twitter
hemos hablado de todas las noticias que
se están mencionando incluso de
inversión que tiene Twitter ha perdido
su valor casi tres veces de lo que era
estamos hablando ya está en 15 mil
millones de dólares a lo que la compró
ylang Mask en su momento el año pasado y
además poder volver a acercarse a los
anunciantes es una plataforma que
realmente vive de la publicidad en donde
muchos anunciantes se han ido pues ya de
la plataforma ya no están invirtiendo en
este caso estamos hablando casi de un
85% que ya nos está recibiendo de
publicidad y ella tiene ese reto
importante Por eso como el perfil que
tiene creo que es lo que tratan de hacer
con ella lograr poder rescatar la parte
económica de la compañía en este caso y
de la plataforma pero es un reto
bastante difícil porque no solamente es
lo económico sino también el detrás de
las políticas que tienen en la
plataforma y además también ya el pues
como la visión que se tiene desde afuera
como usuario de la plataforma también y
que sin duda es una de las preguntas que
discutiremos aquí en nuestro debate
sobre esos cambios que ha tenido la red
social Joan Gracias por acompañarnos Y
de nuevo la misma pregunta para usted
para iniciar nuestra discusión linda y
cariño podrá cambiar el rumbo que ha
tomado Twitter
Hola qué tal Gracias a por la invitación
coincido con mi colega Twitter se
enfrenta varios desafíos hoy en día el
2022 El año pasado fue un año muy
sangriento para las compañías
tecnológicas y este año no se proyecta
mejor más se hizo carga de una empresa
que da pérdidas millonarias y además de
lidiar con la plataforma devaluada
yacarino tiene que bueno ocuparse de de
manejar la personalidad impredecible de
lo más hemos visto como los últimos años
este personaje que podríamos decir que
es una de las personas más influyentes
de nuestra era además de ser nombrado en
diferentes oportunidades como el ser
humano más rico del planeta
es actualmente el dueño de de Twitter y
ya Karina tiene la visión de la misión
de transformar Twitter y un poco como
como mencionó más centrarse en las
operaciones comerciales y como comentó
mi compañera
un poco retomar la confianza de las
marcas y de su audiencia recordemos que
hoy en día Twitter tiene alrededor de
1.300 millones de cuentas que de esas
mil trescientas millones hay más de 300
aproximadamente 300 millones de usuarios
activos al mes y estamos viendo como los
últimos meses perdió perdieron la
cantidad de base de usuarios activos Así
que un reto muy difícil el que tiene que
asumir yarina
Simón Hernández bienvenido y gracias por
estar con nosotros como decía Joan una
de las tareas de linda haya carino será
intentar ponerle límites a la
personalidad impredecible de elon musk
usted cree que lo logrará
Bueno aquí hay un reto muy interesante
que ella tiene que asumir yo creo que a
pesar de que se había hecho ese anuncio
y esperábamos que ella estuviera al
cargo de esta red social más o menos a
final de año y termina todo esto
adelantándose de manera impredecible
como es el estilo mosca como yo lo suelo
Llamar Pues yo creo que hay varios retos
que ella tiene el tema de las ventas el
tema de poder llegar a monetizar será
que lo logra si no lo logra qué va a
pasar y los modos la va a despedir al
igual que hizo con un montón de sus
empleados la verdad es que la
personalidad de él es impredecible como
lo decía mi colega en Argentina y y creo
que no solo le cuesta confiar a las
marcas sino al público pues lo que va a
estar ocurriendo con el futuro de
Twitter Que bueno recordemos que además
de eso ya no es Twitter Inc sino que
tiene otro nombre hace parte de
conglomerado de empresas de elon musk
pero más allá de eso pues también vale
la pena recordar que elon musk dijo que
pues ella iba a ser quien llevara las
riendas de la empresa pues para mejorar
esa estabilidad económica pero que igual
él va a seguir haciendo parte de Twitter
Pues en todo el tema tecnológico y de
innovación y de hecho pues hoy está
dando de qué hablar porque dice que
Twitter va a ser una plataforma de
contenido él quiere que Twitter sea una
súper plataforma Pero además de eso pues
ahí un reto ahí bien interesante porque
le plantó cara a Twitch con este tema de
los creadores de contenido entonces como
que uno no sabe para dónde está yendo
Twitter realmente Cuál va a ser el
futuro y Twitter va a seguir siendo
Twitter o o hacer esa súper app que no
sabemos En qué se va a convertir a
propósito de esa super app recordemos
que elon musk antes de comprar esta red
social dijo que quería convertirla en x
o x en inglés y dijo que sería una
aplicación para todo esto podría
aplicarse desde hacer pagos en línea
hasta pedir comida a domicilio es un
poco la idea de mosc respecto a Twitter
y cuando anunció que linda Jacqueline no
iba a ser sucio dijo que esperaba lograr
este objetivo en Alianza con ella pero
Les propongo que dividamos el debate en
dos grandes temas porque Antes de hablar
qué se puede venir con jaccarino hay que
entender los cambios que ha habido en
Twitter desde que elon musk compró la
red social en octubre del año pasado han
ocurrido tan solo nueve meses y sin
embargo la red social ha tenido toda una
Revolución una Revolución que no se ve
que los usuarios no lo vemos al momento
de entrar a la plataforma o a la
aplicación pero que sin duda Hay unos
cambios profundos y sobre esos cambios
profundos Le quiero preguntar a usted
Andrea porque digamos ha habido tres
grandes cambios la la primera la
modificación del algoritmo que hace que
nuestros en nuestras líneas de tiempo
veamos algo totalmente distinto
empecemos por ahí cómo se hizo ese
cambio y ahora vemos que nuestros fits o
nuestras líneas de tiempo tienen dos
opciones una que dice para ti y otra que
es siguiendo y en el para ti Twitter
elige para nosotros lo que Twitter
quiere que veamos cómo funciona el
algoritmo Y dónde está esa pequeña
trampa ahí Bueno ahí el cambio lo que se
da es que el algoritmo o la plataforma
le va a sugerir cosas que de pronto cree
que usted puede funcionarle dependiendo
de lo que usted consulta a través de la
plataforma Entonces si es que eso ya
persona le llaman mucho la atención
temas de deportes por ejemplo pues le va
a sugerir ese tipo de deportes en esa
columna eso es lo que hace el algoritmo
que se emplea en otras plataformas
podemos verlo En plataformas de
streaming en general eso es una parte ya
en el fit el normal pues va a poder ver
todos los contenidos de esos perfiles o
usuarios que sigue y ahí es donde va a
poder ver todos los contenidos Qué pasa
también detrás de eso hay una política
de de estructuración también de la
compañía De hecho hace muy poco también
se fue una de sus manos derechas que
estaba manejando todos los temas de
inclusión y demás ahí qué ha pasado que
también incluso uno puede sugerir o ver
al contenido y se lo está censurando y
ahí es donde uno dice por qué me lo
censura si yo quiero ver supuestamente
hay una política también abierta en la
plataforma pero se han dado cuenta que
se ha vuelto cada vez más conservadora
hay un sesgo digámoslo así a la
información que se está manejando
también a través de la plataforma y eso
ha generado unas opiniones que de pronto
no le gustan mucho a los usuarios
Incluso si hablamos de medios de
comunicación y demás que se están
manejando y se pierde mucha información
que se estaba manejando anteriormente en
la plataforma debido a esa
reestructuración de pronto le sugieren
contenidos que usted no le llama la
atención y es lo que está pasando ahí
también y esto ha sido un debate desde
que existen las redes sociales y es que
crean una especie de burbujas con los
algoritmos que hacen que consumamos un
contenido determinado La pregunta es qué
lo determina y quién está determinando
lo que los usuarios pueden ver y además
usted mencionó el sesgo desde que mosc
asumió como dueño de la compañía se
eliminaron las reglas de moderación Y
aunque
mosc lo niega a diferentes institutos
como el Center en digital hate afirma
que los discursos de odio han aumentado
que se ven cada vez más tuits en contra
o con discursos de odio en contra de
personas homosexuales de personas afro
etcétera Joan Le quiero preguntar cómo
se ha visto Este cambio y cuál es el
impacto sobre todo en los usuarios
esto que estamos conversando aquí en el
debate se denominan las redes sociales
las cámaras de eco que las cámaras de
eco son este fenómeno en que en que en
las redes y en los medios de
comunicación en donde las opiniones
todas las creencias de una persona se
refuerzan debido a interacciones
repetidas con otros usuarios que
comparten esas mismas opiniones y
creencias eso lo que hace es que se
generen extremos Se generen brechas y
puede esto puedas llevar a una falta de
diversidad de opiniones y a la y a la
creación de burbujas de información como
esta estos discursos de odio extremos en
ese sentido lo que hizo más fue
transparentar el algoritmo de Twitter
poder poder hacerlo público Aunque
todavía esto no no fue 100% Claro en
materia de de cómo funciona y de Cómo
solemos ver los contenidos informativos
estas cámaras de eco pueden ser muy
perjudiciales para lo que es el
pensamiento crítico y la diversidad de
opiniones no solamente son un caso
exclusivo de Twitter pasan en el resto
de las redes sociales también pero bueno
es uno de los grandes desafíos también
que afronta no solamente Twitter sino el
resto de las redes sociales y aquí
también surge el rol de la Inteligencia
artificial en este 2023 que estamos
viendo una carrera por la Inteligencia
artificial donde hoy en día Twitter ya
utiliza Inteligencia artificial para por
ejemplo y algoritmos de aprendizaje
automático para poder predecir los tuits
que un usuario encontraría más
interesantes o analizar miles de tweets
por segundos o detectar y eliminar
cuentas para para fines ilícitos
entonces Inteligencia artificial cámaras
de eco que es un fenómeno social son
forman parte también de estos desafíos
para poder minimizar los discursos de
odio y esta y esta herramienta de poder
transparentar el algoritmo para que
desarrolladores y marcas y el público en
general pueda entender cómo funciona
cómo nos muestra la información y y
poder compr Ender esto en forma crítica
quiero contra preguntar muy brevemente
Usted cree que con mosca a la cabeza de
Twitter estas cámaras de eco se
fortalecieron más
y lo más al comprar Twitter quería
posicionarse como el campeón mundial de
la libertad de expresión no como la
persona clave de la libertad de
expresión yo no creo que sean
disminuidos los discursos de odio ni se
han eliminado estas cámaras de eco o
generado una disminución estamos viendo
un momento donde donde
vemos como extremos muy claramente
marcados y creo que que elon todavía
esto no lo no lo no lo logró Aunque
cambió el algoritmo
que decide qué publicaciones son más
visibles pero bueno hay hay todo un tema
de censura de eliminación de la política
de demoración de contenidos que prohíbe
ciertos tipos de tuits además de los
procesos de amortización hay Acá hay hay
procesos de editoriales que están que se
fueron modificados en los últimos meses
de una forma muy grande Ahora quiero
pasar con Simón hablando de nuevos sobre
los discursos porque tal como ya lo dijo
yoan y los musk se ha planteado como un
defensor de la libertad de expresión
absoluta es decir defender los discursos
incluso cuando una persona por ejemplo
dice palabras que pueden incentivar a
que maten alguna persona por condición
de raza de género de sexo etcétera esto
frente a la otra moneda de si los
discursos de odio deben limitarse o no
que es un gran debate no solo de las
redes sociales sino en general de la
libertad de expresión usted en este
paralelo en este balance que cree que
está haciendo Twitter
yo creo que Twitter a la cabeza de él se
está tomando la libertad de textualmente
hacer lo que le viene en gana y yo creo
que el lobo avisó y lo dejó muy claro
desde el inicio que iba a ser una red en
la que cualquiera iba a poder decir
absolutamente lo que piensa sin importar
si eso puede llegar a ser moralmente
bueno o malo entonces aquí se plantean
varias ideas y además de eso pues uno ya
Digamos como que imagina Para dónde va y
y digamos que un poco ha sido la
percepción de muchísimas personas
Durante este tiempo que llevamos a la
cabeza de Twitter y es que pues eh esta
red ha sido muchísimo más permisiva con
esos discursos de odio y temas que
incluso tienen que ver con sexo o con
política digamos que Twitter no es como
que se haya caracterizado siempre por
tener algunos filtros pero sí ponían
sanciones
recordemos el caso de Colombia a varios
o políticos que fueron sancionados en
sus redes sociales el polémico caso de
la sanción A a Trump y cuando llega Pues
a la cabeza de Twitter dice como que
Okay listo vamos a saldar de nuevo esto
no pasa nada y si quiere Donald Trump
pues puede volver a tener su cuenta
finalmente Donald Trump lo rechaza y
pero digamos que qué ocurre meses
después algunas personas hicieron
comentarios que seguramente ahí los no
les simpatizaron mucho y él estuvo
censurando y guardando la expresión de
algunos periodistas o influenciadores
líderes de opinión en los Estados Unidos
y dijo como que Okay estas cuentas no
van más entonces al parecer es como que
lo que le gusta a él y lo que le
conviene a él y es una persona que en
medio de todo soberbia porque no va a
aceptar críticas ahora bien hay un tema
muy interesante y es que realmente él ha
abierto muchísimo más la puerta a
líderes y a creadores de contenido de
derecha es el caso por ejemplo de token
carrilson que trabajaba en Fox news y se
estrena pues como creador de contenido
luego que se puede Fox news él tiene
Pues esa esa fama de ser persona de
extrema derecha de hablar de esas
teorías conspirativas en contra de la
derecha y pues se abre ese panorama para
que él sea uno de esos primeros
creadores de contenido abanderado de
Twitter Entonces
se estará convirtiendo realmente Twitter
en una red social de derechas a mí me
parece que sí Y usted que respondería a
esta pregunta Andrea sobre todo teniendo
en cuenta lo que nos cuenta Simón que
por un lado reactivan las cuentas que se
habían prohibido como la de Donald Trump
precisamente por difundir desinformación
o discursos de odio Pero por otro
cerraron las de periodistas de
tecnologías se está convirtiendo Twitter
en una red social de derecha Sí y está
un poco selectivo además también con una
problemática adicional hemos visto
muchos casos y en estos días se hable
una investigación que estaba liderando
la universidad de Stanford como
contenidos que se habían ya digámoslo
así denunciado con temas de abuso
infantil se dieron cuenta que nunca se
bloquearon a través de la plataforma
Entonces hasta qué punto está el control
de la información que tienen ahí es
selectivo es lo que les gusta a ellos
que se vea y se vean cada uno de los
algoritmos para las personas o si
realmente están sesgando y quieren que
la gente vea lo que quieren que ellos
estén pues publicando a través de la
plataforma entonces creo que sí y a su
propia pregunta entonces usted
respondería sí están sesgando si está
sesgando totalmente ahora le quiero
preguntar otro a raíz de otro comentario
que hizo Simón Simón dice que
básicamente elon musk hace lo que quiere
y una de las grandes polémicas que ha
habido en Twitter ocurrió Precisamente
en abril cuando elon musk decidió
cambiar el logotipo de la red social el
icónico pájaro azul por el rostro de la
moneda de bitcoin que se llama el
dogecoin donde aparece la cara de un
perro de raza shiba inu Y es que hoy y
los moscas tenía monedas criptomonedas
de dogecoin y justo cuando hizo el
cambio de imagen él estaba vendiendo
parte de sus criptomonedas y ese cambio
en el logotipo hizo que aumentara que se
subiera y se disparara el precio de la
criptomoneda esto teniendo en cuenta que
elon musk no solo está en Twitter además
es el ceo de tesla de spacex también
tiene inversiones En dogecoin cómo está
manejando elon musk esto Andrea está
interviniendo en sus propios negocios y
hace con una red social universal como
Twitter lo que quiere para favorecerse a
sí mismo yo creo que Twitter Fue como un
Capricho de él En mi punto de vista él
tiene sus ojos más puestos en otro tipo
de proyectos como es neuralink ahorita
que lo hemos hablado tanto todas las
investigaciones
implementación de chips ya que se pueden
poner al humano después de las pruebas
que se hicieron en animales con spacex
todo el trabajo que tienen ya de
inversión directamente con gobiernos y
por ejemplo con la NASA y creo que
Twitter fue como por qué no comprarlo
comprémoslo miremos a ver qué pasa como
una prueba error no le estaba saliendo
también por eso pone Pues en la cabeza
ahora a linda yacarino y ahora pues su
enfoque está más en eso más que en
Realmente fijarse si puede sacar a flote
Twitter sino ver que sus otros proyectos
arranquen abarcar todo pues porque
sabemos que tiene todo el dinero para
hacerlo y en este caso pues convertirse
en una persona que siempre sea
mencionada en todos los ámbitos
tecnológicos y pues siendo la
personalidad que tiene es volverse
Popular en todos esos espacios pero creo
que sus proyectos son otros los más
fuertes y Twitter fue más como Un
capricho para tenerlo ahí y en Ese
capricho él pone a Linda yacarino como
sí o y Afirma precisamente a través de
la misma Twitter que ya Karina se
concentrará en las operaciones
comerciales elon musk continuará
trabajando en el diseño de nuevos
productos y nuevas tecnologías Joan nos
estaba diciendo Andrea que Twitter es un
capricho para
mosc usted opina lo mismo y si es así o
no es así qué cree que es el papel de
yacarino en medio de este deseo de mosc
por Twitter
siento que en parte sí también coincido
que que podría ser también Un capricho
de Mask También es importante considerar
el tema este de la de la super app esta
esta aplicación que tenga la intención
de transformar a la aplicación en una
aplicación todo en uno donde las
personas puedan hacer pagos leer
noticias y hasta realizar pedidos de
comida una especie de WeChat la
aplicación popular china donde uno puede
puede generar este este tipo de cosas
creo que un gran rol de chacarino es
generar las alianzas con las empresas
correspondientes para ir camino a esta a
esta super app además de generar mejorar
el algoritmo y mejorar la libertad de
expresión según más recordemos que elon
más muchas veces lo describe como el
cofundador de PayPal una de las
plataformas más importantes financieros
hoy en día a nivel mundial Entonces no
no sería no sería raro que en los
próximos años Twitter empiece a
convertirse en una plataforma más
integral
involucra servicios financieros y desde
mi punto de vista yacarino en ese
sentido tiene una un protagonismo
estratégico en empezar a generar ese
tipo de alianzas para generar el
ecosistema además de de lidiar con una
empresa que como conversamos al
principio durante varias partes de este
debate da pérdidas una empresa donde la
base de usuarios está bajando y donde
las marcas están alejando por todos los
cambios que ha generado entonces creo
que esos van a ser como los Los Dos
Grandes roles que va a tener yacarino
una masa uno más cortoplacista Porque
además de de tener mucho dinero y ser
considerada la persona más con mayor
patrimonio a nivel mundial y lo más que
es un empresario no quiere que la
empresa le vaya mal y en paralelo a
mediano plazo empezar a generar esto que
va a ser de ex Company o ix's
está súper
está súper diría del occidente de del
occidente claramente
en ese sentido Simón qué tan
determinante puede ser Entonces ya
carino para construir los puentes de los
que no vamos a hablar Joan con las
empresas en inicialmente
Bueno ella es una dura del
entretenimiento en los Estados Unidos
ella empezó su carrera en Turner que es
una de esas grandes grandes empresas
Pues de entretenimiento de todos los
Estados Unidos por supuesto un gran
conglomerado de medios de
entretenimiento y siempre siempre se han
encargado del tema de ventas y de
marketing luego por eso va a en b y
bueno allí le fue bastante bastante bien
Y bueno pues tiene una carrera que es de
aproximadamente unos 30 años ella es una
mujer de 59 años y bueno con toda la
experiencia por supuesto del mundo la
admiro a ella por tomar ese ese rol y
tenerle por supuesto la valentía de de
aceptar ese reto pero yo creo que Esto
va a ser un tema de tiempo va a ser un
tema en el que
moscas va a tener que digamos un poco
suavizar su imagen dedicarse a su uso
otros proyectos Así como nos lo
comentaba Andrea porque creo que la
imagen de Twitter si se ha visto Pues
digamos un poco deteriorada desde que
llegó él hay que hacer Pues que a la
gente se le olvide que Twitter es ese
espacio que le pertenece a elon musk Y
dejarla a ella que haga su trabajo
digamos que empezar un poco a ver que
ella puede tomar sus decisiones por ella
misma y que no va a depender
exclusivamente de pedirle un permiso ahí
un mosc si se puede decir que ella va a
ser Autónoma en sus decisiones Y a
partir de eso yo creo que la empresa va
a ser digamos un poco más viable sumado
a esto pues obviamente vamos a tener que
ver otros pasos en cuanto a innovación
tecnológica A qué nos va a presentar
Twitter Más allá de lo que ha sido
durante todos estos años y digamos que
un poco las innovaciones que hemos visto
en el último año y medio que realmente
no han sido tan relevantes Entonces yo
creo que a la larga se va a sumar un
poco a esa innovación tecnológica la
promesa que hace elon musk esperar a ver
cómo fluye un poco esto pero digamos que
la imagen de ella sí va a suavizar un
poco ese ese malestar que ha generado
dentro de la industria
quien ha casado peleas incluso hasta con
Tim Cook entonces creo que le va a venir
bien Además tener una figura femenina
a Twitter esperemos a ver digamos esas
declaraciones públicas que ella va a
hacer ya se llevó a un coequipero que
trabajaba con ella en visillo para
Twitter entonces dejar quedarme de su
equipo pero yo creo que en términos
comerciales el tema pues puede llegar a
ser un poco
indescifrable pero creo que va a
depender muchísimo del discurso que ella
empiece a manejar mediáticamente de
ahora en adelante Andrea y hablemos de
La otra cara o el otro rol a largo plazo
de Linda ya carino y es trabajar para
construir o para volver a Twitter esta
aplicación para todo ex o x dos
preguntas ahí
cómo sería más o menos esta aplicación
para todo para que nos hagamos a la idea
y dos en momentos en los que hablamos de
Inteligencia artificial tecnología la
privacidad está sobre la mesa y es uno
de los grandes riesgos esta aplicación
para todo no le daría más poder ahí elon
musk sí pero pues es la tendencia que se
está manejando ahorita desde plataformas
que se puede hacer todo y no lo decía
también nuestro colega en Argentina
poder hacer pagos pero también poder
tener información de primera mano pero
también poder acceder a canales para
poder seguir cierto tipo de información
entonces lo que quieren hacer con este
tipo de plataformas y que yo creo que se
podría lograr también es poder tener
acceso a todo que se puede lograr a
través de toda la estrategia que ya
tiene por algo pues como lo decía Simón
también ya tiene toda la experiencia que
viene desde el mundo del entretenimiento
y poder integrar todo a través de una
plataforma es el reto el otro reto que
lo mencionaba usted es el tema de la
seguridad la ciberseguridad que es un
reto que no solamente se tiene para las
plataformas para los medios de
comunicación para las redes sociales
porque no es un secreto que esto es una
inversión que se tiene que hacer incluso
desde gobierno no solamente desde las
mismas empresas sino como cuidar la
información se tiene que armar además de
un equipo muy importante Por eso es que
lo decían también se trae una persona de
confianza para poder organizar todo el
tema de políticas y normativa de
Comunicaciones y de seguridad también
para poder manejar la plataforma y así
integrarla Creo que esa es la tendencia
que hay para muchas empresas y no
solamente lo vemos en Twitter Incluso si
nos podemos ir un poquito más allá con
meta lo están haciendo En plataformas
como WhatsApp que uno pueda tener
contenido de acceso a información como
canales que los que están lanzando
también el día de hoy pero también con
comunicarse con la gente comprar a
través de la plataforma y creo que esa
es la tendencia que va para todas
Giovanni ahora dos preguntas para
ustedes relacionadas también con lo que
nos está diciendo Andrea la primera es
usted mencionaba WeChat esta gran
aplicación para todo o una plataforma
Que unifica varios servicios en China la
primera pregunta es qué retos ha
presentado frente a la ciberseguridad
WeChat que de los que pueda aprender
Twitter Al momento de convertirse en ex
y la segunda pregunta es Andrea nos
hablaba que linda yacarino una de sus
uno de sus roles más importantes va a
ser sobre ciberseguridad y las políticas
que va a trazar Usted cree que puede
tener Independencia frente a mosc al
respecto
yo creo que en primer lugar coincido con
con Andrea en que hay dos retos
principales el primero vinculado a la
privacidad Estas súper aplicaciones
pueden recopilar grandes cantidades de
datos personales los usuarios lo que
puede plantear preocupaciones gigantes
sobre la privacidad y más en regiones
como latinoamérica donde las
reglamentaciones de GP Art están muy
lentas en materia de legislativa y bueno
los usuarios pueden ser muy vulnerables
a todo lo que es vigilancia y
seguimiento y los datos
donde se almacenan y y Cómo y cómo la
publicidad está dirigida a ellos así que
creo que es el primer reto de la super
Apps Y en segundo lugar la
ciberseguridad No si estamos conectados
a una sola aplicación estamos muy
vulnerables ataques cibernéticos como el
ransomware como el fishing como el
malware Y eso básicamente la
consecuencia es que los usuarios pueden
ser Víctimas de diferentes fines
ilícitos fraude y
en forma general Así que esas esas dos
creo que la privacidad de la
ciberseguridad son como los dos grandes
retos de de la superaplicaciones al
estilo de WeChat con un sinfín de de
aplicaciones y si ya Karina va a poder
hacerle frente a a más que en esta
realidad también recordemos que hay hay
organismos internacionales que están
involucrados en las regulaciones y
entidades También estamos viendo ahora
recientemente como en la Unión Europea
está trabajando con Google por ejemplo
en una reglamentación para generar un
marco normativo para la Inteligencia
artificial Entonces yo creo que las
instituciones políticas
internacionales también van a influir en
La regulación de este tipo de realidad y
me parece que tenemos que es todo esto
ponerlo en un contexto de una
geopolítica de las plataformas No porque
no es solamente una discusión técnica o
una discusión de Mercado sin una
discusión de geopolítica donde los
gobiernos tienen acá un rol fundamental
en ese sentido entonces me parece que
hay grandes grandes desafíos por delante
para chacarino grandes desafíos para
Twitter como compañía
en general y que y que no es un momento
fácil para la compañía y no es un año
fácil para las compañías tecnológicas en
forma general usted nos introduce a
nuestro tema de conclusiones en medio de
este ambiente y de las dificultades que
ha enfrentado Twitter Simón ya para
terminar y concluir su idea final usted
qué piensa que puede pasar en términos
generales de yacarino al frente de
Twitter y que se puede esperar del
futuro de esta red social
el tema La verdad es que lo veo muy muy
complejo como ya le decía antes creo que
va a depender muchísimo del discurso que
ella empiece a manejar de ahora en
adelante la seriedad con la que se le
tome y y no por parte de de los medios o
de los usuarios de la misma red social
sino también parte de ese comportamiento
que va a tener y los moscas que como ya
lo hemos dicho es una persona
impredecible y pues esperamos que nos
salga contrarearla a que nos salga
digamos a refutar cada una de sus
decisiones y ya veremos Pues realmente
la autonomía que ella pues tiene dentro
de la red social y ese manejo Pues que
se le puede dar de aquí a que sea una
súper aplicación Pues creo que esto va a
tomar demasiado tiempo no es un tema
de la hora yo creo que ella pues como
muchísimos han dicho Viene a pagar un
incendio y es un incendio económico
entonces ella tiene que hacer esos tiene
que bueno digamos que no en vano su
cargo era global partnership de
publicidad
en y Bueno creo que va a buscar todos
esos contactos va a mirar toda esa
agenda que tiene y ver qué clientes
quieren confiar en Twitter y bueno
seguramente confiar en ella entonces
creo que sí Tienen que hacerle como como
un lavado de imagen a Twitter y esperar
si íbamos que pues se aleja un poco de
esa polémica de la que siempre ha sido
protagonista Yo creo que si él se aleja
un poco vamos a tener digamos un algo
muy exitoso para ella en su gestión
lavar la imagen y Apagar incendios dos
labores nada fáciles para linda ya
cariño Joan Cuál es su conclusión
el futuro de Twitter es incierto no
estamos viviendo un 2023 donde las
grandes los grandes grupos tecnológicos
están involucrando planes muy ambiciosos
en cuanto innovación tecnológica estamos
hablando de metas estamos hablando del
grupo alfabet con Google
los planes los desafíos son muy grandes
posicionarse como una súper aplicación
coincido con Simón puede ser un proceso
que tarde una década al menos estamos
hablando de una década el reto
financiero lo veo también como muy muy
grande porque los anunciantes los
anunciantes tal como comentó Andrea son
un factor fundamental en el futuro
financiero de Twitter ya que me atrevo a
decir que el 95% de los ingresos de la
empresa provienen de los anuncios y hubo
una pausa y una reducción muy grande de
sus gastos
como hablamos los retos de privacidad y
los retos de ciberseguridad son
fundamentales y el crecimiento de
usuarios o la o mantener esta base de
usuarios activos también me parece algo
algo importante así que desafíos muy
grandes para chacarino en un contexto en
una geopolítica de las plataformas muy
calente y en un momento de innovación
tecnológica muy grande con la
Inteligencia artificial y al metaverso
también con el lanzamiento de Apple de
hace muy pocos días Así que hay que ver
también la la respuesta del público y
los mercados a toda esta realidad Andrea
y sus conclusión creo que han dicho mis
compañeros creo que tiene que trabajar
mucho en las comunicaciones internas en
el descontento que hay incluso los
trabajadores de la plataforma partiendo
de ahí pues se da todo como un entorno
más sano además Pues el reto que ya
tiene que obviamente es el económico que
pues es la base de la plataforma volver
a llegar a esos clientes para que
vuelvan a pautar porque ha perdido un
porcentaje casi del 86% de sus
anunciantes están perdidos y además
también dar como una nueva imagen de
verdad como Apagar ese incendio que ya
no está en los musk si no está ella la
cabeza y esperar que de pronto funcione
pero es un proceso que lleva mucho
tiempo si quiere lograr tener como esa
integración como lo quieren esa super
aplicación en este caso un futuro
incierto entonces para Twitter según
ustedes lo plantean y un papel difícil
el de Linda ya cariño Gracias por
acompañarnos Andrea Cardona johank y
Simón Hernández gracias por estar aquí
en el debate y a ustedes nuestra
audiencia Gracias por elegirnos la
producción estuvo a cargo de Luis
Fernando Montes y la producción de los
invitados con Tania Herrera Los invito a
que continúen viendo más contenido
internacional en France 24
[Música]